[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec frédéric
jeanjean secrétaire général humides des
bouches du rhône vous êtes donc un
patron de la brasserie des templiers da
cité phocéenne
bruno m'égare ban médecin vous êtes le
chef du service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière dans le 10e arrondissement
à paris alexis poulain qu'on connaît
bien ici éditorialistes bonsoir à tous
les trois merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on vient d'entendre un
le pas parole du gouvernement qui essaye
un petit peu au détour de quelques
phrases de nous remonter le moral de
nous donner une forme de calendrier il
n'empêche il nous dit quand même dans le
même temps c'est à la mode cette
expression qui lie à une hausse
considérable des cas alors je vais me
tourner vers vous docteur tout d'abord
vous en parlerai mieux que personne
quelle est la situation à l'hôpital
notamment dans votre hôpital
lariboisière à paris d'un des plus
grands hôpitaux parisiens
écoutez la situation à l'hôpital en ile
de france comme dans beaucoup de régions
françaises et celles des hôpitaux tendu
effectivement la totalité des lits de
réanimation sont occupées un pourcentage
très important de ces lits sont occupés
par des patients qui ont une forme grave
de kobe de 19
donc en fait nos marges de manoeuvre
s'il y avait brutalement une arrivée
importante de patients l'hôpital est
extrêmement limitée c'est pourquoi
évidemment gouvernement et les autorités
sanitaires propose éventuellement un
renforcement des mesures de restrictions
afin de protéger le système hospitalier
qui pourrait en cas de difficulté ne pas
pouvoir proposer une prise en charge
optimale aux patients qui viendrait pour
les copies de 19 alors frédéric jeanjean
je me tourne vers vous j'imagine ça vous
fait bondir parce que bien évidemment
vous mettez à la place de ce docteur et
des malades et ça doit être évidemment
voilà implacable comme argument on ne
peut pas
congestionné des services d'urgence le
docteur qui propose de renforcer ces
restrictions mais de vous de votre côté
on imagine que vous êtes a bien
évidemment quand on vous parle de
confinement ça doit vous dresser le poil
s'écouter et rappeler maintenant un an
15h ça fera un homme que nous sommes
dans cette situation
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour aider
l'hôpital depuis un an
ça c'était la question que je voudrais
poser gouvernement parce que il s'agit
pas de dire il va falloir opinion il va
falloir mettre des mesures qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour accompagner ont fait des
éclats d'os pour aider nos entreprises à
l'heure actuelle le gouvernement avait
lancé tout un tas de mesures
au jour d'aujourd'hui nous commençons à
peine à percevoir les aides du mois de
janvier
ça fait deux mois deux mois de décalage
je vous rappelle qu'au terme du code du
cowboy nous avons 45 jours il roule
quand un journal ou pas vous acquitter
de nos factures parce que nous nous
avons les crédits à payer on est loyer à
payer analytes était une manière stricte
vis-à-vis de ses débiteurs et bien nous
à ce moment mais nous devons doubler sur
la protection du tribunal de commerce
alors que l'hôpital soit en tension on a
entendu certains gagnent la safer
rappelez vous il ya une norme on avait
les soignants qui se retrouvent là mais
se mettre des sacs poubelle s'est tenue
au cul parce qu'on avait plus de blues
parce qu'on n'avait pas de masque il y
avait beaucoup ça alors qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont fait des annonces mais
concrètement on n'y est pas alors oui on
sait qu'il ya des problèmes
démis cette problématique de l'épidémie
oui on sait que l'hôpital attention mais
derrière il ya une désespérante il est
temps de se lever à travers tout le pays
parce que ces mesures dures et que
concrètement on n'a pas répondu à la
problématique de l'hôpital alexis blanc
c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit
on lisait les nerfs des français à vif
c'est vrai qu'on entend le docteur nous
dire voilà les urgences ont sont saturés
de l'autre côté des français
s'interrogent tous les jours on attend
fébrilement la petite conférence de
presse de jean castex pour savoir à
quelle sauce on va être mangé on entend
la mairie de paris demandé un
confinement emmanuel macron qui ne le
souhaite pas vraiment en ile de france
ce que c'est pas là le problème de ne
pas avoir
on le dit souvent d'objectifs précis de
calendrier précis
alors ni calendrier ni même une volonté
de gérer cette crise de manière
sanitaire je le dit et répété on a géré
cette crise de manière sécuritaire
autoritaire n'est pas sanitaires on a
ces conseils de défense 1 présidée par
emmanuel macron sous le secret défense
donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il s'est dit
ni quelles sont les décisions on a une
une opacité à la fois sur les chiffres
puisque kobe tracker demandent à avoir
accès à des documents
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas par exemple
quels sont les la proportion des
variants sur le territoire national les
chiffres aussi drs qui avait été remis
en cause dans le sud on est dans
l'improvisation permanente de ces
amateurs fiers qu'ils continuent d'être
fiers d'en fermer les français à 18h et
de les enfermer maintenant le week-end
et puis au delà de cette épidémie grave
réel avec le co vide
on va avoir après cela une épidémie de
cancers qui n'ont pas été traités à
temps on a déjà une épidémie de suicides
de dépressions à un grand malaise
psychologique au sein de la population
parce que ça fait un an qu'on ne sait
pas et aujourd'hui au lieu d'avoir un
cap clair au lieu d'avoir une
vaccination qui fonctionne qui démarre
au quart de tour
eh bien on a encore une fois une
campagne de vaccination qui fait pschitt
comme l'avaient fait les masques à
l'époque comme l'avaient fait les tests
à l'époque
tout ça est bien s'accumulent et
commence à faire beaucoup à la fois pour
les français qui travaillent les
français qui ont peur qui sont sujets à
des comorbidités qui aimeraient pouvoir
être vacciné tout ça va très mal et on
continue avec évidemment ses conférences
de presse de jean castex une semaine sur
deux il ne dit rien et l'autre semaine
il nous enferme ça commence à bien faire
alors en tout cas dans la communauté
scientifique certains demandent au
gouvernement de taper fort c'est le cas
par exemple du chef fin du service des
maladies infectieuses de l'hôpital
angèle et piano on écoute je ne vois pas
comment on peut diminuer la pression
dans les hôpitaux sans passer par une
mesure de confinement il faut diminuer
la circulation du virus et ça ne passera
que par des mesures drastiques
il faut aussi donner les conditions de
sortie de cette pression il faut des
règles strictes de déconfinement bruno
m'égare ban clairement il faut des
règles strictes des mesures drastiques
parce que c'est vrai que cette affaire
de couvre-feu à 18 heures qui perdure
emmanuel macron le souhaitent encore
pour quatre à six semaines si j'ai bien
compris avec un confinement le week-end
est ce que c'est vraiment utile nous
sommes fait justement que m les nerfs à
vif un de nos un compatriote
alors vous avez bien compris en fait le
gouvernement a choisi une stratégie de
compromis c'est-à-dire mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
restriction mais quand même limiter les
conséquences sociales économiques
psychologiques de telles mesures sur la
population ont fait fi est effectivement
un compliment
un confinement strict aurait des
conséquences beaucoup bien meilleure ce
mur
la peste de la circulation du virus
malgré tout évidemment il faudrait
fermer les écoles fermer les commerces
donné l'ordre de ne pas sortir de chez
soi et donc c'est extrêmement
problématique l'acceptabilité n'est pas
ne seraient pas bonnes donc il vaut
mieux je pense des mesures ciblées
graduée à la situation épidémique de
chaque région plutôt qu'un confinement
national très strictes qui de toute
façon il devrait être maintenu au moins
quatre semaines pour aboutir à une
diminution significative de l'épidémie
pour permettre aux stratégies de
dépister tracé isolé de fonctionner il
faut pas imaginer qu'une petite semaine
de confinement strict permettrait de
régler le problème et qu'ensuite on
pourrait retrouver la vie d'avant c'est
totalement impossible car aussitôt le
des confinement total instauré
l'épidémie progresserait encore plus un
niveau encore plus élevé que ce à partir
duquel le confinement a été instauré il
faut au minimum quatre semaines pour
pouvoir instaurer un contrôle
épidémiologique
par le dépistage est probablement pour
ceux qui sont amateurs du coc vide 0 au
moins quatre mois de confinement pour
pouvoir le réaliser on voit bien qu
évidemment tout ça aura des conséquences
tout le choix du gouvernement de mesures
certes de restrictions mais néanmoins
compatible avec une certaine qualité de
vie
oui effectivement on le sait maintenant
qu emmanuel macron ne n'est pas
franchement pour le confinement pour lui
c'est vraiment du tout dernier recours
frédéric jeanjean d'ailleurs il ya eu
une réunion à mon âme ou dès lors il
disait tout à l'heure à l'elysée avec
notamment les les restaurateurs ce que
vous seriez prêt à accepter pour ouvrir
et les limites
vous avez eu des échos ça va quand même
dans le bon sens pour vous vous sentez à
la fin du tunnel
écoutez en tout cas on va leur annoncer
qu'ils vont dans le sens quand ils réels
eu besoin de savoir ce que l'on peut
dire c'est que nous avons proposé à pas
vers l'humilité mika
l'hôtellerie-restauration l'ouverture
des terrasses et je faisais remarquer au
préfet de région côte d'azur que sur le
port l opéra de marseille tous les midis
s'agglutinent qui marque plastique par
thème
dimanche sur les bancs ils sont
regroupés on dirait des banques deux
mois la période de la reproduction
ils sont tous là et du coup le lyrique
circulent si vous mourez les terrasses
le laisse passer
on n'est pas arrivé en plein air le
moyen de nourrir les terrasses il permet
de savoir qui est parce qu on envoie ça
permettait effectivement de mieux
contrôler ce qui se passe quand j'ai
commencé le virus à ce que je demande au
pp vous pouvez vous me dire qu'il ya
mangé sur le port ou devant l'opéra les
gars pour les gens s'agglutinent et donc
on avait posé sa ya près de trois mois
nous n'avons toujours pas de réponse
alors faire des annonces nuit c'est
facile on peut les voir
moi je peux faire des annonces vous dire
que je vais raser gratis que cet épisode
mais ceci dit on se rend compte comment
gouverner
qui n'entend pas me reste autour de lui
une logique technocratique
avec on le boit un hôpital où les
problématiques n'ont pas été réglés et
je tiens vraiment à remercier à 6
milliers tout le travail qui paie pour
les soignants il s'agit pas de dire
qu'en tant qu'opposition comprend pas ce
qui se passe mais quand même un problème
de gouvernance gestion qui se pose alors
un autre en colère je voudrais vous
faire écouter le député elle est fille
du nord en rien quoi te lance justement
sur ce thème
on ne peut pas continuer comme nous
sommes embarqués là on ne peut pas
continuer entre déconfinement d'aidé
confinement déconfinement locaux des
couvre-feux il faut renforcer les
protocoles sanitaires et organiser la
société de telle manière que la vie la
vraie puissent reprendre
c'est à dire organiser déroulement dans
tous les secteurs de la société
nous ne sommes pas que des êtres
économique qui se lève le matin pour
aller travailler
rentrer se reposer et reconstituent leur
force de travail on a besoin de se
rencontrer
alexis poulain c'est vrai que cette
liberté confiné on sent que la pilule
commence à être difficile à avaler
j'ai pas l'habitude de parler de mes
propres expériences mais enfin hier je
suis parti voilà du travail à 22h30 j'ai
mis une heure et demie à rentrer chez
moi parce qu'ils ont bloqué le
périphérique
ils ont lancé des contrôles de police y
avait pas d des routiers qui venait sans
doute de faire huit heures voilà deux
camions pour aller livrer des choses
certainement des travailleurs est ce que
c'est vrai que ce genre de mesures est
ce que c'est bien la solution on leur en
demande un avis du médecin mais c'est
vrai que ça commence un petit peu à être
un petit peu lourd pour les français
tout ça mais c'est voyant c'est à dire
qu'en france on répond à une crise
sanitaire avec des moyens de police des
moyens répressifs des amendes à 135
euros à 18 heures on est très fiers de
voir qu'il ya des renforts policiers
pour empêcher les gens d'aller sur la
plage à dunkerque ou pour empêcher les
gens d'accéder au littoral à nice on
marche sur la tête ce sont des mesures
qui sont là des mesures de répression
des mesures de contrôle des populations
mais certainement pas des mesures
sanitaires c'est vraiment la politique
du pauvre parce qu'on a cassé l'hôpital
pour
des années parce que on applaudit les
soignants il ya un an et on continue de
les applaudir parce qu'ils sont en
première ligne qu'ils font un travail
formidable mais ils n'ont pas les moyens
de faire leur travail ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent avec des bouts de chandelles ils
ont été laissés seuls à gérer cette
crise et le reste eh bien c'est quoi
c'est le bâton la mangue 135 euros et
rendre la vie impossible aux français
alors oui une société de roulement
pourquoi pas mais pour ça il faut que
les vaccins arrivent qu'ils soient
efficaces que les gens puissent
ressortir et puis autorisé aussi les
gens à ne plus avoir peur à lire pour
écouter oui la l'épidémie est là faites
attention respectez les gestes barrière
mais maintenant il va falloir quand même
recommencer les gens commencent à penser
printemps les jours se rallongent les
températures augmentent d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui fait que le virus va commencer à
- circulent également
donc là aujourd'hui on est en train
d'accepter un plateau à 300 morts par
jour en disant c'est pas si mal
finalement on va continuer comme ça on
n'aura pas de zéro co vite parce que
c'est devenu impossible on ne va pas
évidemment fermé les gens quatre mois ça
c'est quelque chose d'impossible mais en
revanche on peut commencer effectivement
à rouvrir pourquoi pas des terrasses des
lieux de culture il a été prouvé que ce
n'est pas dans des salles de théâtre et
de cinéma qu'on n'attrape locaux vides
et puis et puis voir comment tout ça
peut petit à petit remettre les gens à
retrouver du bonheur à la fois d'être
ensemble et puis de revivre une vie
humaine de culture de rencontre parce
que évidemment métro boulot dodo covin
ça commence à bien faire
1 bruno mais garvan quand vous écoutez
là vous vous dites voilà c'est une bande
d'égoïstes inconscients ils ne se
rendent pas compte ou où vous comprenez
que cette acceptation devient compliqué
voilà pour pour la population
il ya quelque chose qui tourne pas rond
dans cette manière d'aborder cette
stratégie sanitaire dont évidemment que
je comprends tout ça bien sûr à nouveau
je ne suis pas du tout un défenseur du
confinement
comme mesure de prévention ou de
contrôle de l'épidémie à nouveau ce sont
les mesures barrières le port du masque
notamment dans les lieux clos la
pédagogie la responsabilisation qui sont
les éléments les plus importants même si
on imposait des mesures de restriction
si la population ne comprenait pas ce
qu'il faudrait faire
eh bien on a vous dirai pas aux
résultats attendus en fait il faut
savoir que le confinement notamment pour
que l'on discute actuellement dans la
situation actuelle n'est que parce
qu'effectivement l'hôpital manque de
moyens nous n'avons pas de nous aurions
10 à 15% de lits supplémentaires
notamment en réanimation
nous ne serions pas là en train de
discuter avec malheureusement aucun line
a été créée depuis un an nous sommes
avec nos fameux 5000 lits et tout
compris c'est à dire les lits de
réanimation pédiatrique de chirurgie de
chirurgie cardiaque donc réellement de
façon insuffisante
nous travaillons en permanence à flux
tendu les marges de manoeuvre en cas
d'augmentation de la demande sont quasi
nulles et de fait il faut des programmes
et fermer d'autres services redéployer
le personnel pour pouvoir prendre en
charge les patients la difficulté est là
évidemment le confinement et les mesures
de restriction ne sont là aujourd'hui
que pour sauver ses erreurs stratégiques
commises depuis une dizaine d'années sur
l'hôpital public qui a fini par être
étouffée je rappelle que la situation
actuelle n'a rien à voir avec mars avril
évidemment en mars avril le confinement
était indispensable car une maladie
nouvelle
sabathé sur le pays sans que l'on
connaisse ni les moyens de contamination
ni le cadre médical dans lequel ça
pouvait arriver
ni évidemment les facteurs de risque
aujourd'hui la situation est totalement
différente
on peut parfaitement mesurer la
progression de la maladie simplement
évidemment nous n'avons pas les moyens
de faire face à l'augmentation du nombre
de patients c'est bien compris merci en
tout cas bruno
mes gars ban merci à frédéric jeanjean
en espérant peut-être des annonces
favorable puisqu'il ya eu des réunions
et autour du président de la république
concernant les restaurateurs et merci
également à alexis poulain d'avoir été
avec nous